so the first thing we need to do is we
need to find out you know what are the
coefficients a B and C and because we
have three unknowns that means we need
three equations to solve for those three
variables so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the x-coordinate
we're going to put it in for the axe and
we're going to take the y-coordinate
we're gonna put it in for the Y and
we're going to write three equations so
let's go ahead and do that we've got
three okay is the y equals a times 1
squared plus B times 1 plus C okay
that's our first equation now if we go
to the next point you can see 9 is y so
I'm putting that in for y equals a times
4 squared plus V times 4 plus C and if
we take the third point one is y 2 is X
so we're putting that in place of X plus
C so those are our three equations that
we can solve the system but I'm gonna go
ahead and simplify this down a little
bit further so we've got let's see this
is 1 squared is 1 so that's going to
give us a plus B plus C equals 3 the
second equation I'm going to write as 4
squared is 16 times a plus 4 times a B
plus C equals 9 and then over here we've
got 2 squared is 4 so that gives us 4 a
plus 2 B plus C is equal to 1 so this is
the system right here that we're going
to solve and what you want to do is you
want to pick one of the variables to
eliminate either the A's the bees of the
C's I think here it's gonna be easiest
to eliminate the C's so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to take these first two
equations and I'm going to subtract them
okay so I'm gonna do is I'm just going
to take the bottom one minus the top one
so 16 a minus 1 a is 15 a 4 B minus 1 B
is 3 B C minus C that 0 and 9 minus 3 is
6 now another way that students
oftentimes like to do this is they like
to multiply one of the equations by at
least say a negative 1 and then add
instead of subtracting and you can do
that as well now we've used the first
and second equations we need to use the
third equation as well so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take this third
equation and I'm going to subtract the
second equation from this third equation
so I'm going to do for a - actually you
know what I'm going to do it the other
way let me take the second equation -
the third equation so 16 a minus 4a is
quality for B - 2 B is 2 B C - C is 0
and 9 minus 1 is 8 so now you can see
we've used all three equations we
eliminated the C's and now we're down to
two variables two equations so all we
have to do is solve this system either
eliminate the A's or the B's
let's just go ahead and try to eliminate
the B's since these coefficients are a
little bit smaller so it looks like a 3
B + 2 B we could get a lowest common
multiple of 6 they both go into 6 let me
multiply this top equation by 2 that'll
give us 6 B and the bottom equation will
multiply by negative 3 that will give us
negative 6 B this way when we add them
together the B's will cancel out so
let's go ahead and do that 2 times 15 a
is 30 a plus 6 B equals 12 here we get
negative 36 a - 6 B equals negative 24
when you add these together the B's
cancel we get negative 6a equals
negative 12 divided by negative 6 and
you can see that a is equal to 2 so now
what we need to do is work our way
backwards so if a is 2 let's go put it a
in to this equation or this equation to
solve for B I'll put it into the top one
so that's going to give us let's see
we've got 15 times 2 plus 3 times B
equals 6 so we've got 30 plus 3 B equals
6 subtract 30 from both sides that gives
us negative 24 divide both sides by 3
and we get B equals negative 8
now we know what a and B are we just
need to solve for C I'm going to go
ahead and put those into one of the
equations that we started with
originally with three variables I'm
going to put it into this top equation B
is 2 B is negative 8
C we don't know and you can see this is
negative 6 plus C equals 3 add 6 to both
sides we get C equals 9 now all we have
to do is put it back into our equation
here for a B and C and we've got it so
this is going to be y equals 2x squared
minus 8x plus 9 and that's the equation
of our parabola great job if you're new
to the channel hit the circle subscribe
button below to subscribe to the channel
this channel is all about making
learning math a lot less stressful for
you so you can improve your grades pass
your class and go on to pursue your
I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon